economía nuevo bloque y último de esta
buena mañana que estamos pasando aquí en
directo américa de france 24 no van a
braza mañana raúl y vamos a hablar
entonces el blanca que claro el colapso
de su economía es y rol pues esta nación
insular del sur de asia y 22 millones de
habitantes ya ni siquiera puede importar
petróleo para satisfacer sus necesidades
básicas el primer ministro reveló ante
el parlamento que la petrolera local
ceylon petroleum tiene una deuda de más
de 700 millones de dólares y es por eso
que ningún país quiere ahora
proporcionarles petróleo ni siquiera
pagando de contado
ahora nos enfrentamos a una situación
mucho más grave más allá de la mera
escasez de combustible gas electricidad
y alimentos nuestra economía se ha
derrumbado por completo esa es la
cuestión más grave que tenemos ante
nosotros hoy y es que la economía de
este país se está hundiendo bajo el peso
de fuertes deudas así como también la
pérdida de ingresos por turismo y otros
impactos que vienen de la pandemia hoy
en día tiene suspendido el pago de una
deuda externa por más de 12 mil millones
de dólares y está buscando apoyo del
fondo monetario internacional por otros
3 mil millones mientras tanto sus
ciudadanos tienen que hacer largas filas
para comprar artículos esenciales
danny jamón hasta perú donde habrá un
paro de transportadores de carga pesada
eso es lo que dice la unión nacional de
transportistas que convocó a huelga
general indefinida a partir del próximo
lunes 27 de junio después de no llegar a
acuerdos con el gobierno nacional sobre
el alza en el precio de los combustibles
el presidente del gremio javier marché
se hizo una comparación en medios
locales de lo que cuesta un galón de
combustible
país andino frente a sus vecinos
regionales dijo concretamente que
mientras en bolivia chile y perú los
precios oscilan entre 7 y 9 soles en
perú llegan a 20 soles por galón lo que
equivale a unos 5 dólares a finales de
marzo pasado los transportistas de carga
pesada ya habían iniciado un paro
indefinido por la misma razón y se
extendió hasta las primeras semanas de
abril esto mantuvo bloqueadas varias
carreteras a la protesta en ese momento
se sumaron otros gremios como los
agricultores y eso llevó al ejecutivo
peruano a declarar un polémico toque de
queda en lima y también en callado danny
y eeuu anunció medidas para afrontar las
clases de bomberos claro que si la
administración de joe biden anunció un
aumento temporal del salario para los
bomberos forestales federales y es que a
menudo ellos se enfrentan salarialmente
con los bomberos locales que ganan mucho
más en junio del año pasado badén ya
había aumentado el salario de los
bomberos federales de 13 dólares a por
lo menos 15 dólares la hora en este
momento entonces está anunciando un
nuevo incremento para los próximos dos
años con un pago activo desde octubre en
concreto será un alza del 50 por ciento
o de 20 mil dólares al año lo que sea
menor entre estas dos comparaciones y es
que los bomberos están escaseando en
medio de una feroz competencia por la
ola de incendios sin precedentes que
azota principalmente a la costa oeste de
este país las cifras raúl lo dicen todo
en 2019 hubo 192 ocasiones en las que no
se pudieron movilizar equipos para
apagar incendios forestales en 2020 la
cifra se triplicó y el año pasado ya era
18 veces mayor vamos a hablar ahora
danny de los indicadores económicos como
están las bolsas mundiales están en rojo
raúl en la jornada de hoy en asia el yen
japonés tocó un nuevo mínimo de 24 años
frente al dólar y la bolsa de japón
cerró con pérdidas las preocupaciones
latentes sobre el riesgo de una
extensión empujaron a la baja no
solamente estos mercados asiáticos que
ya cerraron sino a europa que tienen
fuertes caídas a media jornada de hoy
hacemos mención también de colombia cuyo
mercado vivió un día difícil después de
las elecciones presidenciales su
principal índice de la bolsa cayó más
del 5 por ciento en la jornada anterior
y la acción de la petrolera ecopetrol la
firma más grande del país se desplomó en
más del 11 por ciento mientras que el
dólar se fortaleció ya inició una nueva
jornada veremos más tarde cómo le va a
colombia y esta cifra el día no le cae
nada bien a los británicos no señor un
9,1 por ciento fue la inflación
anualizada hasta mayo en reino unido- es
su mayor nivel desde 1982 y los
alimentos tuvieron su mayor incremento
desde 2009 este país tiene ahora la
inflación más alta del grupo de los
siete
daniela blandón gracias entonces por
toda la información nuestro último
bloque económico de la mañana en directo
americanos podemos mañana abanico más
información económica por supuesto